hello everybody and welcome my name is
Derrick Neill I'm the executive producer
here at maximum games and I'm excited
today to be able to bring you this sneak
peek into our upcoming action-adventure
title extinction what you're about to
see is a small slice of one level and
this is a very early pre-alpha build so
please expect some things to change
between this and the final version with
that said let's get started
extinction takes place in a lush vibrant
fantasy world full of painterly textures
and bright rich colors but this world
has come under siege by an organized
army of massive otherworldly invaders
known as the ravenna who have begun
systematically eradicating humanity off
the face of the planet
you play as a viel one of the last of
the Sentinels a legendary group of
warriors with the skills and tools
necessary in order to take down these
massive foes the gameplay and extinction
emphasizes high-speed traversal around
the environment in addition to the basic
jump and double jump a viel can also run
horizontally along walls run vertically
straight up walls air dash through the
sky come floating back down gently can
bounce off of springy objects in the
environment such as building awnings or
treetops and can use his whip like a
grappling hook to get around when he
does this time slows down giving him
time to plan his next move and make
split-second decisions of course a Veals
ultimate goal is to save as much of
humanity as possible he needs to protect
them from the constant onslaught of the
ogres and their minions he does this by
engaging them in real-time skill based
combat in addition to a series of
regular strikes he can also execute
powerful AoE s launch enemies into the
sky slam them back down to the ground
cancel his attacks into rune strikes for
massive damage and cancel his attacks
into dodges in order to evade his
opponent strikes of course the star of
the show is a Veals combat with the
ogres now with their minions defeated
it's time for reveal to take on their
master one of the enormous ravenna who
has been rampaging through the
countryside obliterating everything in
our fully destructible environments the
ogres themselves are fully dismembered
Abul but they wear armor in order to
protect themselves in order to take this
beast down a viel must first destroy
that armor
this is done by a powerful charged-up
rune strike once the armor is destroyed
a veal can then dismember the limb
underneath dismembering limbs like this
builds energy which a veal will need to
ultimately be able to strike the
finishing blow and as you can see this
ogre is none too happy about the loss of
its leg and a veal has to dodge its
attacks while also trying to remove the
remaining armor in order to get to the
limbs beneath them this is an extremely
dangerous situation to be in because if
any of these blows actually manages to
hit a veal it will be death in a single
hit having now absorbed enough power and
weakened the ogre sufficiently a veal is
now ready to go ahead and strike the
finishing blow
using the traversal options we showed
off earlier the veal is able to climb up
the ogres back take out its helmet and
deliver the coup de Gras
that was a relatively easy fight against
a relatively basic opponent but not all
enemies are so simple depending on what
armor weapons and abilities they have
each augur presents its own unique
challenges and requires different
strategies and tactics takedown here we
have an example of an ogre decked out in
gold armor this armor does open up some
new traversal options for reveal but as
you can see it's also much harder to
remove each piece is protected by
multiple latches that must be destroyed
in order to remove it four of them on
each leg piece and two on each arm ease
having finally destroyed all the latches
a veal is now able to dismember the
first of this ogres legs moving on to
the arms however is now much more
difficult as they are constantly moving
making it hard to target those tiny
latches a veal must dodged the ogres
attacks and their minions attacks while
doing this it has now taken sufficiently
long to take down this ogre that its leg
has regenerated and it stood back up but
it no longer matters flush with energy
from his last kill a veal is ready he
climbs up the back of the ogre and is
presented with one final challenge
staying up there long enough to take out
its remaining armor first he removes the
helmet and then the collar with these
two obstacles out of the way and its
neck exposed a veal can finally go in
for the kill and so the second ogre
foams
as I said before this was just a short
glimpse into some early pre-alpha
gameplay and there's much more to come
go to extinction com2 keep up with all
the latest news and reveals and I'll see
you next time